[Music]
richard is with us in tampa hi richard
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay i have a quick relationship
question i'm trying to convince my wife
that we are ready to have children
but she keeps bringing up excuses i
don't know if they're excuses but
she says she doesn't have a career yet
and that i'm not stable at my job
because i change jobs
roughly every three years
so my question is how do i convince her
that we are ready to have children from
a financial standpoint
um how long you been married
we have been married for three and a
half years now okay well george just got
his second french bulldog which is more
expensive than children
and i'll tell you
it is uh it's everything you thought it
would be
but richard
here's the thing you said you changed
job every three years what are you doing
for work
i am an
i.t audit manager so i'm in consulting
okay what do you make
right now i just got a raise and i'm
making 130 000 a year okay all right
this has nothing to do with financial
and nothing to do with your income
uh she has some other reason that she
doesn't want to have kids
and she's using a a a a smoke screen
because people that make 135 000 a year
can afford deaf kids
okay i mean that's just that's kind of
that's mathematically
just simply not true
okay and you change jobs every three
years you're not exactly unstable you
didn't change job three times in three
months you changed up three times in
your career and she hasn't started her
career i mean when you go when you're
gonna start it i mean you don't have to
start a career you can do whatever if
you don't have kids there's one thing
you don't no one's requiring people to
have babies but you guys make enough
money to have babies
so and she knows that i mean if you told
me you're making 13 000 a year i mean
we'd have a discussion here dude about
your job
and you know as a provider and so forth
but you make 135 000 a year you can
afford to have kids
a lot of them really i agree and
throwing a french bulldog i mean you'll
be all right just for fun yeah but you
asked her about her fears around this i
mean beyond just money
does she think that kids are just really
expensive and that it's gonna tamper the
budget
yeah i think there are some
there are some other reasons
uh
so she thinks like healthcare is really
expensive like through my job it's like
10 000 a year to have both myself
covered and
to have both of us on on the health
insurance and she thinks like having a
baby it's going to be
thousands of dollars so she's scared
about that yeah how long y'all been
married
uh
three and a half we're going on four
right now okay how old are you
i'm 35 so i'm getting up there that's
why how old is she
she is 30 right now okay and um how many
brothers and sisters did you have and
how many brothers and sisters did she
have
so i am the youngest of five brothers
and sisters and she is the second
of four
brothers and sisters
both of you had lots of siblings
so um yeah one
so i i i don't know what's going on um
i'll just answer this as the old grandpa
of the group um
with seven grand babies babies are the
best thing that happened to anyone as
far as i'm concerned they're the best
things ever happened to me the only
thing that's better than babies is grand
babies and if i don't know how great
grand babies are going to be i've been
nicer to their parents but the um
uh so you know
but but
and no amount of health care or whatever
you're making 135 000 you're 30 years
old if you're gonna have kids you'll
need to get with it
um
you're already
you're already late it's time to get
rocking here and so um you know i i
think if i think she's not um
she may not even personally realize
why she's really afraid but it's not
money
it's not the finances
something else is worrying her something
else is holding her back and i don't
know what it is and i think you guys
ought to sit down with a good marriage
counselor and not because i think your
marriage is in trouble but to get a good
tune-up sometimes you need a referee to
throw a flag
you know and go okay because if you were
if the two of you were just sitting with
me at dinner and you were like friends
of ours or you would be like kids of
friends of ours or something like that
um i i would just go
all right i'm calling bs
that's not what it is what's really
going on
and she would go no no no no i'm still
calling bs because you're lying it you
guy makes 135 000 a year you're 30 years
old if you're gonna have babies ever
now's the time
800 is healthcare welcome to obamacare i
mean it's what it costs this is what you
signed up for when you voted for him so
here we go
and so
you know this is the deal and uh boom
and you know so decide now what's really
going on what are you really afraid of
because she's really afraid of something
and i don't know what it is but i would
just be grandpa and you can't do that
from the husband position it doesn't
work i mean you can show her on paper on
the budget
we're gonna be okay there's no sense in
arguing a smoke screen objection this is
not the real objection
because it's not it's so far off
it's so such a slam dunk
that you can afford to have kids
if anybody i've talked to this week can
afford to have kids it's you there's
people way bro
freaking six figures i mean you know how
long it was before we made six figures
and we tell people if you're in debt
it's okay to have kids you don't need to
wait i thought you were gonna tell me
all the ways you were broke or something
but um no you're there's something else
going on dude and so i don't know how to
coach you other than to say get a coach
in the room with you that somebody that
both of you can trust to look at you and
to draw those fears out and allay those
fears or deal with them
something else makes her feel
uh vulnerable
she feels insecure
and vulnerable and she's blaming it on
the money but it's not money there's
something else going on
it may be the way you treat her it may
be your temper it may be i don't know i
don't have any idea what's going on but
something makes her feel vulnerable that
she doesn't
feel safe and she because
for ladies money often is a safety
language
it's a language of safety security
glands big pile of money lots of safety
no money no safety you know but here we
got a big pile of money and yet we don't
feel safe so something else is going on
and uh that's my
uh two dollar insight it was probably
worth what you paid for it but
um
you know this thing
he's very wise to ask the question
because this
money stuff is so tied to relationships
and is so tied to our dreams and our
fears and our visions that when we can't
get aligned on it
then then we know something's going on
yeah and there could be something
outside of just their relationship where
there's an insecurity there or a fear
about this big life change happening and
so i think unpacking that with a third
party that could be really helpful yeah
you know and it's not to say you have to
have children it's not required um i i
i'm a big fan of it but it's not to say
you have to
you can i choose to not do that and i
love you just as much and help you just
as much
and not say you're afraid of something
but just go i choose not to that's okay
too